I think this is the first honorary
citizenship I've had from any emerging
nation I will make reference to the
trash aisles from here on out we want to
shrink this nation we don't want any
more plastic added so let's come up with
biodegradable materials instead of this
junk you know I think we ought to have a
price on carbon which would also affect
the economic attractiveness of plastic I
think we ought to have laws and
regulations to stop this wasteful
practice of just throwing everything
away not recycling it coming up with the
so-called circular economy as I
mentioned we're waste becomes natural
resources for other things that we make
and so we don't add to the burden of of
trash and weighs 50 billion tons over
the last 60 70 years it's completely
outrageous plastic adds to the climate
crisis and of course it is absolutely
arming
the oceans and actually some of it shows
up in the fish that people eat now it's
just disgusting
the oceans are crucial to our survival
and we need to protect
[Music]